[Music]
my name is riley keough and this is my
glamour unfiltered
well i had read the thread so i was like
i was just thought it was such a genius
idea
and i was really curious how how they
were going to adapt to twitter threat
and i i'm really in hindsight happy that
i was able to read the thread live in
2015 when it came out
um
and have that experience
um but yeah i was just i just thought it
was a brilliant idea and was interested
in how they adapted what the screen
screenplay would be like
[Music]
i just feel that it's important to show
all kinds of sex work you know i've
i've played sex workers a few times and
on that journey i've learned a lot about
the world and and how vast it is and how
many different types of sex work there
are
[Music]
with stephanie i really just wanted to
do
my job
and do what janixa wanted and that was
really what i was focused on is
delivering a performance that delivering
the performance that jenix and jeremy
had written i just wanted to
take what was on the page and and do the
best you know i could to make this wild
person a real person without also
without making her
um
too
much of a caricature
[Music]
in anybody else's hands i wouldn't have
done this role um janixa is such a
genius and her
subtlety and
uh
and um
like she's just so incredible
that i felt safe
in creating her vision with her um it
wasn't something that was done
there was a poor a purpose to it and
there was a point and it was very
profound
and so
that was um
meaningful to me
i have found that the more that i do
more than i myself and the more that i
am authentic and sort of unapologetic
about
existing which
um the better i feel
so i just try to
um
anytime i can feel myself shrinking i'll
try and push back and i'll try and
notice it in the moment i think
for me it's it's little things it's it's
being in a room at work and
trying to figure things out and going
um
oh nobody wants to hear what i have to
say pushing myself through that going
i'm just going to say it you know
because because whatever the worst worst
that could happen is that nobody you
know that we don't use my idea you know
and that's not and that's that's
not so bad what is is keeping it in and
making yourself small so i just like i
notice it in the moment and it's little
things and i'll be like okay
i'm i want to say this but i'm not
saying it why you know then i'll just
i'll just push through it
[Music]
i almost would play dumb when i was
younger i would kind of just be you know
and and i'm not dumb at all i'm very
very smart you know so it was this weird
thing where i was like kind of trying to
figure out
how to manipulate and how to be able to
just be myself but with with other
people's projections of me and other
people's
you know ideas of me and
i don't know like it's just it's been
such a weird experience being a female
[Music]
well i think that that is the two side
thing where there's things that there's
things that people are putting on you
and there's things you're putting on
yourself and sometimes you can't tell
the difference you know sometimes i'll
walk into a room and
and think you know all these people are
whatever they're thinking you know and
it's just me i'm just making that up in
my mind you know and i think being able
to tell the difference uh when those two
things are happening is really important
[Music]
i'm like a bit of a hippie so for me
success is like when i have inner peace
i see a lot of people
who think
when i get this then everything's gonna
be okay or when i mean
when i'm this then i'll be happy and i
just see through that and i don't think
that that is reality
[Music]
when i did zola i met taylor and taylor
um
taylor and i are very similar people and
when you meet somebody that you're very
very similar to it is a very spiritual
experience and then at the same time i
really felt that from junixa in and
and
also when you have that as an artist
when you have a director who you really
feel like understands you and your work
and your
craft that is also this like incredibly
spiritual experience
i love women and i love um i love having
female friendships and they they've
absolutely been the most important to me
yeah female friendships and female
relationships have been
the most important relationships of my
life other than my marriage
we're told by instagram and
and social media that you know if we're
not getting up and running and drinking
our green juice and yoga and hiking and
and having 20 babies and being happy and
and wholesome all day long that we're
doing it wrong
and i think that it's really
a sick way to look at life life is
challenging and and
life is is great and it's difficult and
i think we're in a society where we are
told that happiness is the goal and
i don't believe that and i think for me
in 2020 that was
um
what got what really what i really
came to understand in a different way
[Music]
i meditate a lot i meditate a lot
i
i
love it it really helps me i've had
anxiety since i was 14 really bad panic
attacks um
horrible
horrible anxiety um
and
that was something and i would find
myself running from it as a kid and in
my early 20s just like
whatever i can do to not feel that
something that i really like about
myself is i don't care about those
things if i fail at something i don't um
i don't get stuck on it i kind of just
let it go and and you know if i do a bad
take of a scene i'll i'll kind of be
like [ __ ] you know how do i fix it how
do i do it better